une frappe russe à deux heures du matin
sur cette base de défense ukrainienne au
nord du pays
une autre qui a détruit cette usine
d'équipement militaire à 150 km à
l'ouest de Kiev
une zone d'habitation bombardée dans le
même secteur
l'offensive russe s'intensifie sur tous
les fronts
cette ville au sud de la capitale a été
touchée pour la première fois hier un
missile a détruit une partie d'un
secteur résidentiel pas de blessés mais
des Ukrainiens encore sidéré de voir la
guerre surgir dans leur quartier
je dormais ici mon frère était sur le
canapé c'est arrivé à 9h du matin j'ai
eu tellement peur jamais j'ai eu aussi
peur de ma vie
la guerre sur le terrain et la guerre de
la communication toujours le ministère
de la Défense russe publie une nouvelle
fois les images de son déploiement ici
le dispositif présenté comme se
rapprochant de Kiev face à la Russie qui
resserre son étau la réponse des
Ukrainiens la voici toujours de longues
files d'attente devant les bureaux de
conscription militaire des centaines
d'hommes jeunes ou moins jeunes prêt à
prendre les armes renferré regardez
terminé
c'est mon devoir je vais être utile je
veux protéger mon peuple je veux que ma
famille revienne en Ukraine dès que
possible
une main sur la vitre d'un bus
leur des adieux pour ce père qui ne sait
pas s'il reverra le visage innocent de
son enfant
dans le sud du pays l'incertitude sur le
nouveau cessez le feu décrété à Mario
Paul ici des volontaires s'activent pour
accueillir les milliers de personnes qui
souhaitent quitter la ville à siégé il
trouveront notamment refuge dans ce
cirque devenu silencieux la population
épuisée espère que la trêve aura bien
lieu